you're watching the GameSpot stage on
koat.com we don't have enough reasons to
say the word GameSpot ran here
I'm Daniel Dwyer from GameSpot and I'm
delighted to be joined by Jimmy
Whisenhunt senior designer on h1z1 yeah
that's right how you doing my friend
I'm excited man I'm awake this is the
first e3 we're like this part of the day
I'm still awake I have energy it's been
a lot of fun just take care of yourself
last night yes I did I went straight to
bed it's a hard thing to do but I
managed to do it
h1z1 for folks who don't know what it is
just give us the sort of broader pitch
I've wanted what's different about your
zombie survival game because you know
call a spade a spade here there in a
number of zombies to five other games
out there absolutely it's it's turned
into a genre right and we've always been
big fans of that genre and the guys
working on this project have pretty much
been hand-picked like we've all migrated
because we like working on this type of
game and we want to play it
it's an MMO that's one of the biggest
things with us is that Sony Online we
work on large games we want to we're all
about sandbox gameplay and really giving
a player the experience they want and
we've opened development practices with
this as well I know you talked to
landmark earlier and that was yeah yeah
big thing with us as well but it's
post-apocalyptic and it's about forming
your own story and trying to survive
just imagine you're dropped off in the
woods you don't have your phone there's
no GPS so satellites don't work anymore
and you've got an axe what are you gonna
do I mean you have to figure that world
out it's a lot of fun excellence I said
SOE seem to be a barking on some very
interesting projects I know you worked
on planetside 2 as well and what what is
it about what are you trying to do here
that you think other you know like the
daisies and the world and why not what
is it admit having this kind of the
angle you're taking that thing separates
it away from from those competitors I
guess sure well kinda how it all started
is once again almost everyone on the
team worked on planets and has dealt
with his engine before so we looked at
the engine we said what can we do and
what would be really fun with this and
we're all big fans of the daisies and
the genre in general we wanted to see
our own take of it there's some things
that we really enjoy about survival that
we think other people would as well and
a lot of that has to do with really deep
crafting and experimentation with
different types of ingredients and
exploring a world we're starting with
the 64 square kilometers and growing
into other areas of the United States so
we're really really excited to see where
this goes because really help it having
the players help us direct it cool so
let's deep dive on some of that stuff
then let's talk about the crafting and
what it looks like from what
h1z1 is that the onus is very much on
the idea of survival and the
difficulties therein so you said you
don't start with much in you in terms of
your what you have in your inventory
what are the types of stuff you will be
crafting and how far does that go sure
so there's two different types of
crafting in our game there's your
personal progression where you might
craft a bow and arrow or you minecraft
something like a spear to go fishing and
that sort of thing and there's also
crafting things that you're gonna put
into the world and that might be a
foundation for a home the walls that go
within that and storage sheds and all
that fun stuff
starting in the world with the axe
you've kind of looked through your
initial recipe list you've only got five
in front of you okay and kind of the
common sense was a campfire you're
trying to survive might be dark when you
log in and you need wood and you have an
axe we want that to be intuitive and the
first thing you do is run up to a tree
and you chop the tree down it'll fall so
you've now made noise and we might have
seen that fall zombies earlier what was
that let's go find out what that was and
from there you're just gonna work your
way through you can opt to build
something like a spear or something that
actually this is the first time we're
talking about it is we're gonna put in
thrown Spears and some very improvised
weapons there still are your assault
rifles and that sort of thing in game
but you're only gonna be able to find
those they're incredibly incredibly rare
and then on the top end of a view and
you're actually building shelters and
places to live and whatnot yeah
absolutely
the Foundation's kind of the first
beginning of that there's different
types some are better than others in the
way they're bigger and some of them have
stilts so you have more area to put them
down on the side of a hill and from
there it's free form walls throw a roof
on it put some storage inside of it and
become self-sustainable in the world
there's dirty water you can fill up your
bottle with you can drink that it's
gonna hydrate you but it's gonna hurt
you instead of having to deal with
filtering that as you get your home in
your little area you can get things like
Dew collectors and catch rain and get
fresh water that way and that's really
kind of where the high end goes and
James Mack on Twitter asks a very good
question can we play the game without
even having a gate without engaging in
social interaction or do we have to
communicate for some features so
presumably you know some of the one of
the best ways is to survive is safety in
numbers so it's it's the game you're
going to have to engage other people or
how are you gonna it's definitely not
gonna be a requirement but it's highly
recommended yeah we we're leveraging the
world against players and we're not
afraid to admit that it's gonna be much
more challenging to what people
used to there are hordes of zombies the
zombies are difficult to kill and
there's not a lot of ammo I was as we've
kind of been running through the game we
have her on the floor on a natural
amount of ammo in the game's 300 rounds
so yeah that's incredible and okay and
I've run out of that ammo trying to
escape one pocket of zombies so coming
up against friends or coming up against
people and at least trying to talk your
way through the the psychopath just meld
the Internet's mind and hope he can help
you yeah that might be a good move but
you never know we're not gonna try to
keep our players from communicating or
make them communicate I do recommend it
though guys I'm serious I really do I
guess one of the problems with
eventually getting good at any one of
these games is that at a certain point
like you said you you have enough
firepower that perhaps packs of zombies
especially if they're kind of dumb
zombies like people might be used to in
Jay Z if the challenge sort of stops and
perhaps that's why humans start turning
on humans more how are you guys gonna
stop it soda at a certain point you when
your player is comfortable where they
built their house where they have their
walls up they are safe sustainable with
food maybe and they have some sort of
water purification that the world is
still challenging for them so it's you
kind of create exponential problems for
yourself so the more noise you make the
more zombies show up and the more angry
they get and the more other types of
wildlife you attract the larger you
build out the more attention to again
again right the undead in our game is a
little more intelligent than what people
are used to we actually were talking
about it with some of the players we had
a situation where our system once again
this is emergent AI I don't we haven't
talked about just yet but zombie was
running through the front door and one
of our devs closed the door and the back
door was closed as well so he turned her
he's like I'm gonna go this way and he
opened the door and the thing was
waiting for him oh wow ran around the
back super fast and I caught out of the
corner my running around the side so
it's it's not you're not gonna outsmart
a bunch of these guys I mean of course
people are always going to be the most
intelligent and I guess unpredictable
foe but zombies themselves they do make
a lot of decisions you might not expect
sometimes so do you when you're crafting
this game you're obviously going to try
and then ensure the players are at least
adhering to some sort of social forum
where like summer Red Dead Redemption
for instance when they're multiplayer
people were tying folks up and sticking
them on railroad track
some of the problems with other zombie
type games is that often there are
groups of bandits going around attacking
freshly respawn players and how much is
player versus player combat an onus for
you guys and how will you try and
address problems that can arise from
opie players meeting new players so
anything's really possibility there's
always the wildcard factor once again
one of the first things you're gonna be
able to do it'll take a little bit of
time but to get a bow together and to
get a spear together that might sound
super inferior but let's really think
about this both through the head is a
pretty effective now granted that's a
slow projectile and it's only gonna fire
one at a time but you still have a shot
to fight these people if you run into
them and as an experienced player who
has a gun you're gonna need these new
people and hopefully we're gonna see
people trying to help them out because
on their own with all their ammo they're
just gonna keep bringing more and more
hordes of zombies and wildlife to them
they need to try to help recruit people
and so you guys been pretty active on
Reddit as well there's lots of
conversations about the future of this
game because this is a it's an SOE you
guys are pretty much on top of the free
to play yazz stuff so I know that you
guys are still thinking about your
monetization and do you know in which
ways you're going to bring that into the
game because the initial worry would be
oh man all these zombies are killing me
I'm gonna spend 10 bucks and get this
massive rocket launcher absolutely I'm
gonna pay $10 and run ten meters a
second or something yeah we we don't
want to touch the hardcore survival
aspect of the game because that's why we
love it and that's why players like
these sort of games it's the tension and
the evens that thought with it in the
back your head I could throw some money
at us and suddenly be fine we want to
avoid that so stuff we're looking at
selling or cosmetic stuff and we're
still having a lot of conversations
about it and the cosmetics won't be the
same as you find in the world things in
the world will keep you warm and will
affect you in some way this kind of
stuff would not okay we're still in
discussion with other things okay I
guess you guys have been pretty I
remember will planetside 2 you're pretty
vocally community as well so yes it's
it's interesting from somewhere in the
press site to see that channel happening
because often we are the conduit so like
it's cool to see that happening another
aspect of that I've read about is the is
the cost idea of custom servers and you
guys have do you have a max player count
all ready for the the servers we're
still feeling that one out because the
world will grow so when early access is
really gonna help us on Steam
it's really gonna help us figure out
what number is that fine balance between
seeing people and not feeling like
you're in a big death match yeah so
it'll keep growing though as the world
grows and the is the custom server stuff
would that be maybe something down the
line like allowing players the ability
to create their own because obviously
from a business standpoint that causes
issues yeah so being an MMO company
we're very proud of our architecture and
then how many players we can support and
everything we're gonna host all the
servers we have looked at we've talked
about this extra publicly giving people
tokens and the ability to vote on
certain rule sets okay the next server
that spins up it could be a different
rule set people want to see zombies with
more HP they do more damage or maybe
there's some penalties to tearing down
someone's home or more PvE base force
PvP we have a lot of options because
once again we're leveraging forge light
the planetside 2 engine so there's a lot
of things that we can turn on and off
per server and we want to make sure we
keep that moving forward cool hip lit in
the GameSpot chaffed asks and what type
of character customization is there so
in terms of both setting up your
character initially and then going on
thread the thread your experience at age
1 0 yeah actually a good question like
right now we have a white guy in the
game and then from there we're gonna be
going out to male female all races will
be in there and that'll be about it for
the character customization on the
character create but when you get into
the game itself we have the shirts the
pants the backpacks are gonna change
different hats if you want to be the guy
that stands out all the time and dressed
in bright orange you're more than
welcome to of actually to that point if
you wear a massive Hawaiian red and
white shirt well the zombies maybe
notice you more in the wood I haven't
thought about that alright you can have
that one for free I like in the game spa
chat ask what kind of weapons are
available so you've talked about the
sort of low end axe a bow and arrow and
whatnot and what are we talking about on
the on the top and then in between ok so
initially in the game we're gonna see it
in ar-15 and m16a4 and you're gonna see
pump shotgun 12-gauge a 308 hunting
rifle and it'll grow from there I know
for a fact right off the bat we're gonna
have the m16 ar-15 and 1911 in the game
and we're gonna roll out from there our
goal is to get the basics of each system
in so players can help kind of direct
where to go okay and we're gonna
continue to grow out with more and more
and more guns iso 2000 as well and then
what I'm looking at here is voguing
memories of we're watching the second
half of the Walking Dead Season just
just last week and in terms of vehicles
obviously that's a that's an important
aspect of that universe and if you're
creating a world which spans a great
distance then vehicles are a useful
resource but are you know probably more
it's probably more interesting if
they're rare so how are you guys
tackling that do you have vehicles in
the game and how often you come across
them so there are vehicles in the game
right now right now it's an off-roader
it's a four-door Jeep ish type of
vehicle that's four-wheel-drive all that
fun stuff
and that's where we're gonna start with
early access and B because of the
systems and things we've learned from
planets I have a very dynamic system we
can have aircraft one day if we so see
fit to throw that in and we can put in
cars we can have all kinds of different
stuff in the game and we will yeah do
you think you're gonna get it cuz you
can you can kind of go crazy with that
stuff if you want you can you can do
underwater stuff you can have flying
that sort of stuff yeah we are we are I
mean really once again getting that
offer in there first and seeing kind of
what's missing from the puzzle we'll
decide what we do now okay and again
it's an MMO so it is a it is a you can
go two ways with that you can go the you
know rust has a sort of an open
structure where you were all a sort of
like multiple Minecraft where you are
lots of people existing in that world
and there are bodies and antagonists and
you have to kill them and the
traditional MMO we would see especially
what guys we'd EverQuest next on would
be a more crest paced scenario h1z1 are
you guys gonna have a sort of main are
you gonna have quest lines or are you
just are you basing this on emergent
gameplay and what the players create
themselves so it's gonna be based on a
mirja gameplay I a lot of the content
we'll put in will just kind of
inherently drive players to new areas
because starting in this kind of
northwestern feeling rolling hills area
play with that for a little while and
suddenly there might be an available
cityscape they can wonder their self off
too they could just keep going an old
direction and find something new so
those will be driving forces behind the
game because in these new areas will be
new sites and new things available to
work with but no they're not gonna be
any quest lines or anything like that
again hey Jonathan Pierce on quiet on
Twitter sorry I'm trying to get as many
of these in his posture absolutely he
asks if you die in the game do you have
to
we start from scratch or will you keep
any of the items you've crafted so I was
respawning working and so it is a
permadeath game what is on your
character when you die is lost now this
is really fun I love it now I think
about this for a second I really want
you to think about this so you die and I
mean we're familiar with you all the
RPGs and everything where you have to go
for a corpse run like crap get my stuff
before sub else grabs it right you come
back in your undead selfs walking around
so you might end up having to fight
yourself to get your stuff back there's
a problem to that too though is you're
gonna see that that was a person he's
got a hat on you're like wait that's not
a normal yeah and you go kill that thing
there's a reason to kill that zombie
because who knows what that character
had on him before he died and also sad
part about it is if you die you might go
wandering off somewhere before they find
yourself it could be a week before you
find yourself and that so if you die you
restart re-roll yep new dudes you get to
keep your own name though we're not
gonna really immerse you create a brand
new character won't say you know
so-and-so will live on in infamy or
something like you actually get to keep
your name I love it
absolute pleasure gym ear is done thank
you so much for coming on h1z1
and folks want to get a hold of it when
is it gonna be available and on what
possible we're working towards it every
day man we're trying to get to early
access we'll make sure we have the basic
said before we throw that in it's it's
it's coming very very close very very
close awesome thank you very much for
coming out and enjoy the rest of you
three thank you